두 남자가 정확히 같은 날 비트코인 거래를 시작했습니다.
한 명은 하루 12시간 동안 차트에 매달려,
모든 양봉을 필사적으로 쫓아다녔습니다.
하지만 어젯밤, 단 한 번의 '고래 함정'이
그의 평생 저축을 모두 날려버렸습니다.
반면, 다른 한 명은 어땠을까요?
그는 가족과 저녁을 즐기고 평온하게 잠들었으며,
다음 날 아침 5,000달러의 수익을 확인했습니다.
이 차이는 운이 아니었습니다. 시스템의 차이였습니다.
한 명은 '먹잇감'이었고, 다른 한 명은 '승자'였습니다.
대부분의 개미들이 실패하는 이유는
고래들이 설계한 게임에 놀아나기 때문입니다.
그들은 '사라'는 신호에 맞춰 매수당하고 있지만,
세력이 함정을 치고 있을 때 당신은 그저 사냥감일 뿐입니다.
Trap Defence BTC는
보이지 않는 함정을 시각화하여 판을 바꿉니다.
우리의 엔진은 기관의 시세 조작이
당신의 자산에 타격을 주기 전, 미리 그 징후를 포착합니다.
승률이 당신의 편이 될 때까지 안전을 유지하는
최고의 트레이딩 기술인 '절제력'을 제공합니다.
이것은 고위험 시장에서 살아남기 위한
최첨단 생존 전략입니다.
그리고 오늘, 당신은 이 장비를 무료로 갖출 수 있습니다.
지금 바로 Defender's Academy에 가입하여
Trap Score 'Minimum Edition'을 무료로 받으세요.
카드 불필요, 과장도 없습니다. 시장의 생생한 진실뿐입니다.
더 이상 털리는 개미가 되지 마십시오.
당신이 '시장의 지배자'가 되는 것입니다. 아래를 클릭하여
봇을 실행하고, 지금 바로 무료 액세스 권한을 확보하세요.
지금 시작하세요.